hello everyone and welcome back to the
things we're all very excited for frozen
- to premiere on November 22nd 2019 in
the meantime though we thought we'd
bring you a frozen theory that will have
you rushing back to rewatch the Disney
classic be sure to watch until the end
because we'll be giving you the craziest
little details that tied together this
frozen theory do you think you could
show us away we know that all of you are
pretty big fans of Elsa Anna and pretty
much all of the lovable characters that
join them in their crazy adventure
there's Olaf the sweet and loving
snowman that was magically brought to
life by Elsa Kristoff a charming and
silly ice Harvester whoo-hoo anna runs
into while she's searching for her
sister finally who could forget Sven the
reindeer who definitely played his part
in helping the sisters make it through
their icy journey in today's video we'd
like to focus on some characters whose
backstories were kept a mystery by the
Disney filmmakers backstory on Hans
first starters we've got the antagonist
of the movie Hans of the Southern Isles
according to the first movie Hans is
only interested in getting Princess Anna
to fall in love with him in order to get
access to the throne of arendelle Hans
is first introduced to the audience as
one of the princes of the southern Isle
he's the royal representative of this
country that was sent to attend Queen
Elsa's coronation Princess Anna
accidentally finds herself colliding
into his horse during the beginning of
the film and gets knocked onto a boat
this is when we first see Hans use his
charming smile and good looks to seduce
the princess his smile looks totally
genuine and this isn't the only sweet
gesture we see during the coronation he
can be spotted sweetly waving to Anna
from the crowd he later joins the
princess for a ballroom style waltz
after coincidentally bumping into her
again the two seemed to immediately hit
it off and Anna opened up to him about
her relationship with Elsa and how she
wishes they could be friends again
like when they were younger being the
sweet prince that Hans supposedly was he
then promised to never shut her out
before the pair broke into song now we
hope you guys have been paying close
attention to these details because here
is another one that is crucial to our
theory about the character
I just can't this guy's awake so I'm
awake so we have to pray why hunts is a
good guy wenona and Hans go to ask for
Elsa's blessing the duo's plans are
halted when Elsa refuses to let onna
marry her newfound lover convinced that
Hans must have ulterior motives also
orders him to leave this leads to a
confrontation between the two sisters
and Elsa ultimately exposing herself and
her powers this shocked everybody in
town including Hans who clearly had no
idea that Elsa had any powers to begin
with when Tana decides to go after her
sister Hans even agrees to stay behind
to watch after the city and the people
of arendelle he's seen distributing free
blankets to the public and even setting
up food lines in the palace this is some
pretty sweet and thoughtful behavior for
a man with evil intentions not only does
he do these things despite criticism
from the Duke of weselton
but he also defends Anna while she's
away when the Duke insinuates that Anna
and her sister may be plotting against
their own town in people Hans responds
furiously calling the claims treason and
I will not hesitate to protect arendelle
from treason
Hans only ever agrees to leave when he
believes Anna is in danger since her
horse returns to the town without her
now with all of these details we found -
Hans is either a total evil mastermind
or a pawn in someone else's game
Hans working against his own plans we
know what you guys are thinking he's
probably just an evil mastermind who was
able to fool us all with his great
acting skills but here is why this might
not be true for starters he's constantly
working against his own plans
Hans and his men eventually run into
Elsa instead of Anna this is where he
saves else's life by getting in the way
of a bolt headed her way this would
actually have been a perfect moment for
him to secure his place as Ana's husband
and therefore king of arendelle through
their marriage trolls theory with that
being said we can think of a group who
might just be responsible for Hans
sudden change of heart
we're talking about the trolls the
trolls are a group of creatures that
live in the valley of the living rock
Elsa and Anna first run into them as
kids in a scene where they're both taken
there by their parents
Anna is accidentally hurt by Elsa's
magic while they're playing together and
so the king to say
that the trolls might be able to help
these creatures clearly have a history
with the royal family since they're even
spotted in the book in this book we see
an ancient relative of the family that
looks as though he's been placed under a
curse
there's also a troll standing above him
and clearly trying to extract the magic
from his body now keeping this in mind
the only people who clearly have the
ability to change minds and maybe even
hearts are in fact the trolls if you
don't think that's possible just
remember that these are the same
creatures who were able to remove years
of Ana's memories once she was cured she
had no recollection of Elsa's powers
whatsoever despite being depicted as
adorable and bubbly characters the
trolls also seemed a lot darker and
suspicious on the page of the Kings book
the page of the book tells a dark story
and gives us an awfully wicked vibe
instead of a helpful one just looking at
this page it's hard to believe that the
trolls are there to help the king
instead of hurt him for those of you who
still don't think these guys could be
evil here's another motive you won't be
able to deny fixer-upper scene in the
scene where the trolls seeing the catchy
tune fixer-upper we see that they're
pretty determined to set up their
adopted son Kristoff with Princess Anna
they sing about how her engagement is a
flex arrangement and that all they need
to do is get the fiancee out of the way
if these guys had such great intentions
wouldn't they have just found a way to
cure Elsa and possibly show her how to
control her powers instead they compared
her powers to a curse and speak about
how dangerous she's going to be this is
probably not the best way to help out a
scared child and could definitely
explain all of the trauma that
eventually drove the sisters apart they
also erased all of her sister Ana's
memories doing the pair's relationship a
lot more harm than good
so do we think it's possible that Hans
is innocent and was being controlled by
the trolls the entire time but we've
decided to dig a little further to get
to the truth sometimes I really don't
like you Hans family theory there is
also a lot of evidence that points
towards the theory that Hans could in
fact just belong to a family that
mistreats him and pretty much forced him
into trying to deceive the two
princesses of arendelle it is said that
Hans apparently had an incredibly rough
childhood and suffered a considerable
amount of
lect at the hands of his family it is
the result of this upbringing that
totally could have driven him to be
manipulative and obsessed with powers in
order to prove his worth and earn the
affection of his family hans may have
decided to put his morals on hold and
pique his love for princess onna now
don't get us wrong we aren't saying that
we don't stand behind what we said
before mom's definitely look genuine
during this time with onna at the
beginning of the movie not to mention
the lyrics to love is an open door that
both he and onna were able to come up
with on the spot these lyrics included
phrases like it's crazy we finish each
other's sandwiches
that would definitely be a lot harder to
come up with if he had to fake his
feelings at the same time - not to
mention that he was in fact finishing on
his sentences which only adds to our
theory that Hans was being genuine the
entire time and may have been under the
influence of somebody or something else
if Hans actually grew up in a horrible
and wicked family then his motives would
make sense according to the frozen
timeline Hans and Ana's relationship
starts off incredibly romantic and
genuinely convincing but what could have
happened if it wasn't the pesky trolls
and their possibly evil magic well if we
look at the root of honza's problems we
know that they stem from a lack of love
in his life
so what moment in frozen could have been
a turning point well if we had to guess
we would say the moment falls somewhere
around the time he started gaining the
trust and love of the people of
arendelle to jog your guyses memory he
did this through ensuring that they were
taken care of during the endless winter
that Elsa started
we can't help but feel that it was this
newfound love and admiration that Hans
felt in the moment that left him longing
for more this would make sense but not
totally explain his evil actions after
all Hans could have still maintained his
plans by kissing Princess Anna and
eventually ruling by her side the only
explanation we can think of which makes
Hans is sudden change of heart
makes sense includes a mix of both
honza's family and the trolls trolls in
family theory in all the movies that
include magic and spells we usually find
the characters more able to be
controlled when their morals are
weakened and they're feeling vulnerable
if we're right and Hans was starting to
enjoy the power and respect that came
with the love of the people of arendelle
then perhaps it was in this
moment that the trolls were able to
control haunts and his emotions during
the trollsnews fixer-upper scene the
trolls seemed to be using some magic
even if it was just for show Anna even
ended up fainting if you're a real
frozen fan then you may have realized
that honza's intentions still seem pure
and genuine right up until the moment
that their faces were close enough to
touch could this just be a coincidence
or it could it be that the trolls used
Anna as a messenger for their magic this
would make sense and totally fulfil
their intentions of getting the fiancee
out of the way we don't know about you
guys but the timeline seems to be a
little too perfect to leave us convinced
that this was just a coincidence and not
in fact planned by Disney's frozen
creators
we're totally rooting for a possible
explanation that confirms our theory in
frozen - since Hans is confirmed to be
coming back for an appearance a fun fact
to know about the frozen franchise is
that the story is based on an original
tale by writer Hans Christian Andersen
considering this fact we just can't
imagine why the frozen writers would
decide to name the antagonists of the
movie after the writer of the original
version in Anderson's renditions of the
film the trolls actually had a mystical
magic mirror that was said to make your
eyes and heart dark it would make it so
that you could only see the darker side
of things and only feel ugly and dark
emotions emotions that don't include
love and empathy as for what the actual
directors of the film had to say about
this theory they've apparently gone on
record to say that just isn't true they
claimed that the trolls were monk to be
lovable characters with no evil
backstory and even give the fans that
came up with the theory credit for being
so imaginative this could be the case
but could also be a way to prepare us
for a total plot twist in frozen - we
want to know what you think be sure to
let us know in the comments section
below we hope you enjoyed getting to see
these Disney characters from a totally
different perspective
maybe Hans really isn't so bad after all
do you wanna take kristoff to be your
trolley wait what you're getting married
and that's the end of our video be sure
to subscribe to the things and don't
forget to give this video a big thumbs
up thanks for watching see you guys next
time
[Music]